hey let's go Ambrose my name yeah sorry
anyway today's a very very very special
day because we're finally starting a new
let's play on this channel doesn't
happen very often anymore I know because
I wait for actually interesting good
games to come out okay I'm sorry
alright probably gonna be a lot of
people playing this one so if you're
watching this one you're watching the
right one don't worry about don't worry
about any other the other little aid
play on normal
it contains hopefully this series won't
get demonetized
all my other horror videos got
demonetised for a while so the story is
where Linn lager Mun sounds so Swedish
or German yeah it's an investor
generally seeking the answers behind a
pregnant woman murdered under impossible
circumstances in rural Arizona when I
first play this I thought they said the
Amazon you are Blake longer man her
husband this isn't a cameraman record
everything neither of you are fighters
to navigate the horrors waiting for you
in the desert
your only choice are to run hide or die
I'm so [ __ ] pumped to play this you
know outlets to was one of the games
that were you were spot that we filmed
for scare PewDiePie season 2 and it was
so fun it was me and Ken is such a crazy
episode [ __ ] I'm really disappointed
that one isn't coming out now that I
[Music]
oh [ __ ] this is cool Jessica Jessica I
know if guys night I was dreaming about
Jessica her kids really loved industry
an intro okay oh yeah all right cool I
swear I have the exact spoken camera
it's a Sony nicer oh [ __ ] yeah we're
good we're [ __ ] okay yeah yeah all
right how's it going getting great shots
here she strangled herself to death
here let me try and I can serve as an
intro for the whole piece tell me what
we're good okay
recording we're good two weeks ago a
young woman was found wandering barefoot
oh no that's an EMP boy [ __ ] in the ushe
oh my god
hold onto something please
[Music]
excellent great hey I like the new intro
we didn't get to see you last time we
played we have played the demo so you
might recognize some bits in their first
episode probably oh [ __ ] we're starting
up in the school
this looks so [ __ ] good Jesus oh
jesus please don't prank me Jesus I have
a lot of a lot of things - they really
polished it up it's it's way way more
polished now I like it Jessica thanks
Jessica
Jessica all right Jesus you got great
ABS never let oh oh hey bald man what
did you do to Jessica Aaron jeez so in
some form of Catholic school probably
great a lot of you guys get big lockers
in America [ __ ] hell we we got to share
like half this size and in Sweden we
have winter jackets I don't know why I'm
talking about this right now this is
clearly not the right time [ __ ] what is
the sound going win exit oh how nice
great let's go god damn it Oh jessic
jessica
Jessica's stealing her moves from the
shining what the [ __ ] Jessica oh [ __ ]
okay we landed here landed I love a good
leg it must be my and top-quality new
computer tap repeatedly hey my camera is
intact my trusty old Sony camcorder ah
my wife is dead my wife is 100% dead let
me add subtitles I always forget
professional youtuber everyone when Lynn
Glen or Lane that I didn't find Lynn
nothing matters but Lynn what about
cleaning your nails cuz honestly they
look nasty dog wait I can look at the
footage I recorded that's all son I said
[ __ ] first death already I am we're back
Oh Shaq and jump down here and it what
Lynn where I yeah ah [ __ ] I'm sliding
Lynn good thing I'm a rock clamber what
not a problem not a problem as long as
you don't scream like a little [ __ ]
you'll be fine cuz at least then you
dine on it
up a little bit okay drop down okay got
it
Lin what when important events should be
captured when the Rex signed blinks amis
you're aiming correctly at the recording
event aim at the event okay so now we're
recording that's cool so it's actually a
part of of this one cuz I know you can
do it any other games but it's not
really a it's not a really an important
feature so we can play it wasn't there
everybody wasn't in the wreckage she
could still be alive
I like this [ __ ] they're stepping it up
this game I can tell Jesus [ __ ] Lin use
night vision raise the camera and press
f here we go [ __ ] it's so creepy dude I
know why night vision is so creepy
could be the lack of color and light oh
[ __ ] oh [ __ ] me
alright very murder car D mission crash
oh [ __ ]
[ __ ] this he looks like the doctor from
the first game doesn't he
alright so we press tab to watch it
right sorry let me review footage yeah
pilot I don't even remember his name
though oh that was a pilot the [ __ ] kind
of people would skin somebody alive oh
Jesus Christ Lee maybe someone that
really likes to eat skin you know
how long was I asleep that's the real
question what the [ __ ] damn you look
good man
okay oh [ __ ] this is creepy god this is
really [ __ ] creepy
you can look back by holding oh yeah I
remember that uh jeez
geez Louise potatoes squeeze I want to
suck on your teeth why oh why is my hair
so [ __ ] animated eh what is happening
there that's better killing it here we
come what am i recording here
now there's a town
do we need to review all the footage I'm
just kind of curious I'm supposed to be
anything for miles it's really cool
feature
okay we don't need the camera right now
conserve our battery it looks amazing
I know it's not like I don't know a
[ __ ] crisis or whatever but oh it
looks tight I'm lost and hurt we played
this part [ __ ] this part
ah God is anybody there
Jesus saved me man come on man hey you
got me some baby dose Thank You chief
says how about next time you get me a
helicopter hey man are you doing man
oh [ __ ] never mind my dearest wait I can
take a picture of it how do I take a
picture
I can't bear with what we've done not
being apart from a little ones God burns
me forever ah these things happen you
know I'm sure I'm sure he died a natural
death I'm sure he lived a happily long
nightlife eating chicken wings
you ain't whoa whoa whoa what the [ __ ]
are you doing chicken wings batteries
when the moanings gone and you can't go
on bed Reed Hey
somebody's pulled the door jab bladder
[ __ ] stop we're fine IRA fine because
what the [ __ ] are you doing man whose oh
my god all right fine I'll go this way
moustache man thank you very much must
oh [ __ ] we got something here
hey it's a cow how you doing ah they try
to do a Star Wars you know when they
yeah hello anyone here not even a door
handle
well [ __ ] hey a tricycle I can ride
this I can ride this back home finally
I'm saved
I'll come back for your tricycle I left
you jab blah Fichte [ __ ] ah
what are you doing with that what
happened he man hello
hey they got electricity in here oh [ __ ]
[ __ ] is that Sam that does not sound
bueno
molto non bueno edge said forgot about
that jump scared Jesus Christ [ __ ] enter
the window press space while moving
towards it what can't see it it's called
jumping all right we got to find more
battery because we're running out of
battery I got more chicken wings you
know you're in this stuff because you
got them chicken wings boy there must be
a battery here come on I know there's a
spare battery here somewhere
yeah just cuz I can crawl underneath the
bed game doesn't mean I'm gonna actually
do it hey unlock that [ __ ] top bottom on
and down oh yeah here we go doing great
so far brush it's almost like I've done
this before thank you you're so kind
honestly let's reload okay we're fine
Jesus is with us we're fine we're fine
everyone what the [ __ ] was that I'm sure
it was a friendly police officer looking
to save me just in case I'm gonna go in
here oh [ __ ] I remember this [ __ ]
heart hallelujah
stay in a stone
hallelujah baby have had a pack
shut up baby you don't know me why do
you look so [ __ ] ugly I will get your
channel recording pack god damn it
no let's I know you're working for
you're working for the evil name oh [ __ ]
this party ha ha ha
don't mind me just walking over burned
babies not a big deal or anything
wasn't there something down here
[ __ ] okay this way
all right yeah this place is [ __ ] baby
turnip ah babe oh my god there's Babies
everywhere
someone must love collecting dolls just
as much as I do
we're crawling out here wait this is
different they changed it okay that's
cool so from now on we don't know what's
gonna happen I don't know if I like that
Bruce all right what do we got what have
we got
shut the [ __ ] up I'm not baptized all
right who's saying that what what just
happened I just wanted to get the
direction home man
[Applause]
[ __ ]
let's hide here okay we're fine we're
fine we're fine we're fine we're fine
we're fine
shut up we're fine we're fine everything
is fine I've never been this fine in my
goddamn life I'm fine we're fine
everyone's fine everybody's happy and
fine where did she go what a [ __ ] go
hello hello where did that [ __ ] go
hello I just want to know where did that
[ __ ] go yeah I just want to know where
did that [ __ ] go okay we're fine
chop over the morning chin here what and
we're inside everyone let's find some
batteries it's that [ __ ] into here
I mean batteries hey bandages glad you
just when the morning's gone and you
Hank come on unlock that [ __ ] hey has
anyone seen my wife my wife should be
out here oh [ __ ] I swear I did this in I
did this and scare PewDiePie
where is that [ __ ] where's that [ __ ]
where is that [ __ ] I don't know where
the [ __ ] [ __ ] it I'm just gonna go it
stresses me out so much god damn it I'm
just gonna [ __ ] go [ __ ] this
go go go go go go go go go yes yes Bunch
[ __ ] off
we're safe I'm safe high five we did it
you can move objects by holding ok where
am I supposed to move it
backwards no oh god is she coming in
here [ __ ] I don't like her all right I'm
gonna be honest here I either tend to
not judge people right away until I know
them I just don't like her I don't like
her at one second let's read this note
chapter eight and all your people have
made war all right that's a great story
I think I'll save it for when my life is
not being threatened by a crazy lady
with a goddamn crotch all right here
where are we
we're crawling we're crawling everyone
that's fine I've crawled before I can do
it again what's that it's a light okay
we're fine all right
oh my god she better not be there she
best be not be here
get in your glasses [ __ ] it really I
don't have guys oh Jesus oh hey how you
doing you look good you know it'll just
be dead okay
uh all right well you know thank you for
your feedback poor Scott it's got in
this game that's awesome mind god it's a
Minecraft god evening let's go out here
but fine everyone hey it's the same I'll
take the same libero ha ha
I'm Riley
okay let's ignite a nice comfy home nice
old comfy house you can hear through
walls and track sounds with your
camera's microphone your camera is
equipped with a microphone press v2 here
cool there's sound coming from there
well we should probably not go in there
then let's clearly people outside hey
chicken we're okay I think it's safe now
surprise it's me poopy pants waist-high
pants okay we got to reload
we can hide in barrels what that fukk
good game I don't know where I'm
supposed to go it's very disorienting
when you see this low is that a pooper
Hey look someone have Mexican
Hey look someone had nothing okay okay
all right he's walking time don't hit me
I'm a grass I'm a grass I'm a grass
goddamn it I'm a grass I'm being grass
right now that's right keep track press
think like a grass free like a grass run
like a grass [ __ ] certain entrance [ __ ]
oh [ __ ] it's thank God for it again hi
guys yeah [ __ ] [ __ ] you gotta [ __ ] them
out of here look my wife [ __ ] everyone
hell yeah hell yeah I'm out of here
oh god it's a church in the church
everyone I mean it's not that big I've
seen all right pros I'm gonna have to
end that episode there if you enjoyed
please do leave it like I really really
appreciate all the support and I'll have
another video up tomorrow at the same
time for your bra's I can't wait to
share this adventure with you guys and a
virtual brofist